make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I just woke up a little bit ago
so my voice is gonna be deeper than
normal
throughout the course of this video
those you guys who don't know my voice
gets super deep in the mornings it's
kind of lightning it can get really deep
like super deep it's kind of crazy but
um but anyway so we're continuing on
with our story on Batman right and like
in the last video we where we ended this
of course the fight broke out between
Batman and and flashpoint Batman right
like Bruce Wayne and then his father
from an alternate universe Thomas Wayne
who was a far more extreme version of
Batman I mean he had no qualms with
killing or anything like that and so
when this fight concluded all we saw was
a hand just kind of reach up out of this
giant pit and we didn't know if it was
Thomas Wayne or if it was Bruce Wayne
and so what this does is this basically
kind of switches over to Gotham City
presumably with the defeat of Batman
with the defeat of Bruce Wayne all
indications that he hasn't been seen we
don't really know where he is although
we will find out and then we just
basically pick up with like the Joker
and the Riddler and it's kind of crazy
here because we're driving in a police
car and they are for all intents and
purposes acting like police officers and
what they're doing is they're actually
arriving at a murder scene regarding a
character named double X now double X
was actually is actually a guy named
Simon X or at least he's half of the
equation so back in 1958 with Detective
Comics 261 the idea here for DC at the
time was to create Batman stories or a
rooted in science fiction right we
talked about that multiple times over
the course of this channel right like
the 1940s comics were based alone on
World War two and with Barry Allen's
introduction in 1956 DC sought to blend
traditional superhero themes with
science fiction themes because science
fiction to become so popular after the
end of World War two and superheroes had
dropped off in popularity after the end
of World War two and so creating a kind
of winning recipe here with Barry Allen
the result was it going forward science
fiction was brought in to the origin
stories or to the ongoing stories of
superheroes and so with this kind of
going down the way that it did Simon X
was introduced as a guy who believed
that humans had what were called auras
kind of like an nth internal energy
source and the idea here was that he
believed it could be harnessed and then
be used for its own ends the result was
that everything went awry and so the way
this played out is you have X which is
essentially Simon X and self and then
you have double X which is basically his
aura his energy given physical form is
basically at the same powers of Superman
- like frost breath and things like that
but basically in this scenario he's been
killed off and we don't really know why
and in reality it's not really important
that we know why I mean he's just a
character that's been around
for a long time the real takeaway from
this is that you've got Joker and
Riddler who are functioning like cops
and they're saying cops things right
there talking to commissioner and then
it turns out the Commissioner is
actually Hugo Strange and so the way
things seem to be seen be playing out
here under the rule of Bane is that all
these villains have taken over the role
of cops and it really doesn't make any
sense right because when the question is
asked like are you gonna set up the
signal then the answer of Hugo Strange
is yes and they fire up the bat signal
so you look at that and it's kinda like
okay this doesn't make any sense because
if Gotham City was taken over by the
villain vane then you would believe that
it would just kind of be allowed to
descend into madness what we saw with
regard to the events of The Dark Knight
Returns that you know people wanted a
communist state so they got a communist
state and it wasn't what they thought it
would be while like he was masked
pandemonium because human nature was
thrown into the mix where people kind of
consider themselves to be above such
base level things but you know giving
humans the ability to do what it is when
they want how they want suddenly leads
to to absolute torment now in reality
what you saw in the Dark Knight Returns
was not a communist state it was an
anarchist state that's basically what
you saw but but the the overall gist
here is that Gotham has seemingly been
taken over entirely by villains and when
the Batman shows up of course it's not
Bruce Wayne it's Thomas Wayne and so the
indication here is that Thomas survived
and Bruce Wayne didn't or Bruce Wayne's
still laying down there at the bottom of
the pit we don't really know instead
what we get here are these small little
pages where there's just a guy in this
like this really really cold suit making
their way through like this freezing
cold and that's basically if I like will
see that from time to time we'll see
like that page kind of thrown in there
from time to time but it actually
becomes a huge point of the story later
on which is one of these is why I love
Tom Kings worked but from here we switch
over to Thomas Wayne basically going
down into into the Batcave and being
served by the ventriloquist right I mean
the ventriloquist kind of having his
thing Reese really it was easily
manipulated but again it's everybody who
works for Bane basically running the
show here in Gotham City and Thomas
Wayne is looking at all this he's saying
okay so double X basically had
super-strength and had enough to fight
to stand on par with Superman which is
true but basically what he says is if
this was going to happen if double X was
going to be taken out then somebody big
would have had to have been the one to
do it and what he's done is he's
basically we worked Gotham City's a
seismometer in order to you know where
it normally determines earthquakes and
instead focuses on similar locations and
then keeps hitting to two-face I said we
don't know exactly what it is that's
going on here all we know is that
essentially Thomas Wayne is picking up
shakes in the ground and then saying
like these guys have to be
for two days or something along those
lines and so what we end up doing is
picking up with solomon grundy in with
amygdala who are working directly with
to face and that's when the explanation
really begins to come out right because
these guys are taken out pretty fast but
they're not taken out by Batman instead
they're taken out by Gotham girl of
course if you guys remember Gotham girl
being kind of an allegory for Supergirl
who was brought in at the very very
beginning of Tom King's run and it's
sort of been free-floating in and
suffering from exposure to the psycho
pirates emotional manipulation up until
this point but she's been working for
Bane basically and so it's it's kind of
like she's sided with Bane's character
and so it gets kind of nuts because when
she goes in here and she starts fighting
amygdala and in Solomon Grundy it's
obvious she doesn't really know what
she's doing and she's not really
receiving proper training and that's one
of the big differences between Thomas
Wayne and Bruce Wayne Thomas Wayne he
wasn't necessarily as nuanced as Bruce
Wayne was Bruce Wayne was a lot more not
really subtle I mean he was insofar as
like his ability to be stealthy and be
very very ninja-like but in terms of his
ability to Train Robins effectively he
was exceedingly good at that it was keep
your mouth shut
be quiet function accordingly now Thomas
Wayne has tried to do that the issue is
at Thomas Wayne's lacked the ability to
kind of full-on enforce that it's one of
these things where he has Gotham girls a
sidekick but isn't really control Gotham
girl and so the result is that she tears
these guys another really terrible eye
she takes him apart quite easily and
that's basically the end of that and
then of course like like two-face puts
the gun to his head and says like if you
keep going I'm gonna pull the trigger
and Harvey Dent's gonna be gone and then
Batman throws a Batarang and catches him
in the eye and basically severs the
nerves in his brain that had these dual
personalities you know not necessarily
curing two-face but really kind of kind
of screwing him up and that's what we
end up learning that what's been going
on here is that two-face is one of the
last few villain holdouts when Thomas
Waynes showed back up in Gotham after
his fight with Bruce Wayne and basically
it was establishing like Bruce Wayne is
gone now like Bruce Wayne's not part of
the picture Bane made his move and Bane
began taking over Gotham City what he
started doing after that was in order to
basically turn villains to his cause
because the Joker loves chaos because
the Riddler loves riddles because they
wouldn't readily serve someone else he
basically started using psycho-pirate
and so he would bring them all into
Arkham Asylum he would have
psycho-pirate throw on his mask and then
he would basically have psycho-pirate
used the medusa masks ability to
manipulate emotions forcing the villains
to become essentially henchmen and to
learn to love Bane and so that's really
how he's controlling things two-face is
one of the last villain holdouts he's
like no no this is my city he's one of
the last few villains who hasn't been
yet and using like amygdala and using a
solomon grundy they took out double X
because double X is a guy working for
Bain that's been trying to basically
capture an and bring an to face as it
was kind of nuts when you get into that
because the way this plays out a psycho
pirate comes in and basically puts on
his mask and says you love bein like you
you love him as a character the other
half of that is that Alfred is still
alive and Alfred's in Arkham Asylum but
all the various members of the bat
family are kept at bay seemingly because
Alfred's more or less being held hostage
I will kill you if you guys come in here
therefore they've all kind of been kept
away in this story right now we don't
know what they're doing so it's kind of
a cool moment because again with Bruce
Wayne making his way up into this this
monastery or this building out in the
middle of nowhere he suddenly set upon
by these guys who essentially look like
criminals right and they they work for
magpie whom at half force works for for
Bane and so Bane's reach extends
everywhere like all across the globe it
reaches all over the place and it's kind
of a cool thing because what these guys
say is that like if he has anything
we're selling they should take it and
then give it to magpie and the magpie
can sell it off to Bane basically making
them super rich and they just kind of
leave Bruce Wayne out there in the cold
as it was kind of crazy because it's
it's one of these things worse like okay
this is gonna be the end of Bruce but
when you get into this discussion it's
it's awesome because one of the things
that Alfred really displays here is an
ongoing loyalty to Bruce and he talks to
Thomas and he says I feel bad for you
and and Thomas is like why like what
would you have to feel bad about me for
and Alfred says because I feel bad about
you about what will happen when he gets
back when Bruce Wayne comes back I feel
sorry for what he's going to do to you
the other thing about this is it's
somebody this this person who's been
making their way up there has been
either trying to locate or or follow
Bruce Wayne or what have you and that's
when this person really kind of starts
talking to him because Bruce Wayne is
just kind of muttering to himself right
like it all started on the boat in a
sense of Batman vol 1 I am Gotham it's
sort of like the arrival of the plane
rather that was starting to go nuts and
then it brought in Gotham and Gotham
girl and basically it all started in the
very very early days the response to
this person is no no no no it did not
start in a phone it was started on the
street and we end up finding out this
person is Selina Kyle this person is
Catwoman she's here to essentially
rescue Batman and that's the cool thing
because remember Catwoman does not work
for bein Catwoman did not walk away from
the alter what does she do not walk away
from marrying Bruce Wayne because Bane
told her to that was never the case she
was manipulated by her friend Holly who
works for Bain and it basically
believing that Batman cannot be half
unless he's Batman she's as much of a
victim here as Bruce Wayne is and so
that's kind of the cool thing because
she's the holdout here and I love this
because what it basically means is that
like Gotham can be retaken by the
combined efforts of Catwoman and Batman
it's pretty awesome to see like it's
pretty sweet to see how this whole thing
goes down but again
Gotham at the MoMA right now is in a
very dark place villains who are
masquerading as cops who kill regularly
the average person won't really commit
crimes because they're terrified in the
face of like super villains and those
individuals who's who aren't like
traditional cops right I mean like if
you if you look at it from a
psychological standpoint it's true that
like extreme punishment does not curb
crime but it's only because extreme
punishment is carried out by like the
average person right but like we're
talking about a super villain a person
with the power to read minds or a person
to force you into believing that you
were rabbit and you walk around that way
for the rest of your life with no
control over yourself we're talking
about things that are that terrifying
where they can just turn your body
inside out then fear will ultimately
take over and fear will be the
guaranteed factor that will keep people
in line because the fear is so extreme
as opposed to just normal circumstances
but again it's an awesome story and I'm
really diggin what it is a Tom Kings
doing but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]